le troisième point le troisième point
sur lequel je voudrais insister je
terminerai par là parce que les autres
sujets on va en débattre pendant des
mois
c'est la menace terroriste sur la menace
terroriste d'abord je veux dire aux
sénateurs la très grande gratitude et
reconnaissance qui est la mienne pour la
manière dont les débats se sont noués
sur l'état d'urgence sur les lois
antiterroristes au cours des derniers
mois dans cet hémicycle sur l'état
d'urgence je salue le travail
remarquable qui a été fait par le
sénateur mercier que je ne veux pas
compromettre par un excès le compliment
mais qui est vraiment a fait un travail
tout à fait remarquable sur l'état
d'urgence
sous la direction de philippe bas pour
lequel j'ai également de l'estimé pas
pour ce qu'ils pensent pour des raisons
qui tiennent au fait qu'il est dans mon
département et que les normands ont tout
intérêt à être solidaires tellement ils
sont peu nombreux et j'ai pu constater
aussi que sur toutes ces questions
lorsque l'essentiel était en jeu la
représentation nationale à l'assemblée
nationale comme au sénat a su faire
montre d'une certaine unité d'une
certaine cohérence
et même lorsque j'ai eu sur la loi
renseignements ou sur d'autres sujets à
devoir affronter des débats je pense à
la sénatrice benbassa ou à la sénatrice
à 6 qui était plus tonique
vous l'avez toujours fait avec un grand
respect de ce qu'étaient les quais sujet
et une grande compréhension de ce qui
était aussi les contraintes du
gouvernement je vous le dis parce que je
voudrais vous inviter sur deux textes de
loi ce que je dis est sincère et un
temps un tout petit peu intéressé il ya
deux textes qui arrive le texte
renouvelant état d'urgence et un
deuxième texte qui concerne les forces
de sécurité à travers la légitime le des
conditions d'engagement des armes
l'anonymisation il faut que sur ces
sujets pour les forces de l'ordre
précisément nous retrouvions le même
souci d'unité de rassemblement et puis
sur les forces de sécurité intérieures
je voudrais là aussi vous dire
simplement les
11 je suis là c'est parce que je ne veux
pas vous donner le sentiment d'être
atteint par le syndrome du cacatoès de
répéter toujours la même chose et il y a
eu des suppressions d'emplois quand je
vous le dis ça vous agace beaucoup mais
elles n'ont pas été sans impact quand
même sur le fonctionnement des forces de
l'ordre près de 13000 nous en avons créé
ça vous agace aussi je parle de
l'opposition et parce que comme vous
pouvez pas tout à fait contesté que vous
en avez supprimé
parfois vous contestez que nous en ayons
créé mais peu importe je pense que des
pas sont ceux là allons au delà des
échéances qui nous qui se présente à
nous essayons de vous de parler aux
forces de l'ordre elles mêmes qui sont
quand même comme vous l'avez dit très
sollicités qui ont besoin de voir la
représentation nationale dans toutes ses
sensibilités leur adresser des malles
des émeutes des messages forts et là
aussi éminemment républicain
l'effort sur les forces de l'ordre
devraient être maintenus
quel que soit le gouvernement qui sera
en situation de responsabilité dans les
années qui viennent si ce que nous avons
fait en matière de réhaussement des
effectifs et des moyens d'investissement
n'est pas maintenu vous aurez des
difficultés collectivement et donc moi
je je veux quand même profiter de mon
passage à matignon
d'abord pour agir tout est minuté toutes
les heures ensuite pour donner envie aux
français de continuer avec nous je le
dis quand même et 3 pour faire en sorte
que ce que nous croyons nécessaire ne
s'arrête pas si un autre gouvernement
devait advenir dont il faut maintenir
les efforts sur la sécurité à la fois en
effectifs et en moyens d'investissement
et il faut le faire aussi dans une
perspective européenne je le disais tout
leur talent parce que beaucoup des
sujets de la lutte antiterroriste sont
des sujets européens éminent système
d'information schengen connexion des
fichiers directive hama armes à feu
lutte contre la fraude documentaire
capacité de déclencher des exercices
frontex et croyez moi
sur tous ces sujets union européenne
n'est pas unanime et donc s'il n'y a pas
une france forte dans l'union européenne
pour pousser les dossiers comme nous
avons essayé de le faire jusqu'à présent
ce sera extrêmement difficile voilà
monsieur le président
archer mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais vraiment vous
remercier du fond du coeur pour la
qualité de ce débat j'ai bien compris
que je n'avais pas convaincu tout le
monde le président de sce sarlat
présidente assassi mais c'est pas grave
parce que dans les cinq mois qui
viennent il y aura d'autres aux caisses